Speaker 1: Most people in my audience probably
agree that the United States is special, but you
might disagree in the ways in which the United
States is special. But the US is right up there
with Russia as one of the only two major countries
in the world in terms of opposition to the covid
vaccine. This is data from a morning consult poll
of more than 75000 weekly interviews on the topic
of the covid vaccine. And it looked at vaccine
opposition and it also looked at reasons for
vaccine opposition. In the United States, 20
percent of the population is unwilling to get
vaccinated. We knew that number from before. That
number seems to be holding steady. One in five
Americans says they will not be getting vaccinated
in Russia and only in Russia. Is that number
higher among the countries surveyed where 37
percent of Russians say no vaccine. Now behind the
United States are Australia and France, with 17
percent vaccine opposition, Germany at 16 percent,
South Korea at 12 percent. If you look at Japan
and UK, only nine and eight percent respectively
are unwilling to get vaccinated. Now,
there's something important to consider here
in the U.S., 20 percent plan not to get vaccinated
when we have the top vaccines in the world
fully available. The testing in the Russian
Sputnik vaccine actually has been sort of murky.
And so while Russian opposition is higher in
some sense, it makes sense because of the sketchy
propaganda and nebulous testing data around
that vaccine. Russia promoted their vaccine as
the world's first covid vaccine, making sort of
a show of the speed with which they put it out.
They've also pushed some ineffective covid
treatments like ARBIDOL and grippe Feron and
Carrousel. So there actually might be more
empirical reason to be skeptical in Russia.
And if you look at the reasons why people
are unwilling to get vaccinated in different
countries, you'll see that in Russia. Forty three
percent of the vaccine opposed say they're worried
about side effects. And twenty five percent
are worried that trials move too quickly.
It actually does seem that they did in the US. The
reason for oppositions are 34 percent side effects
and 32 percent trials move too fast, which is a
Republican talking point here that is not based in
reality. Trials moved at exactly the speed that
they were supposed to. The Phase three trials
were completed. There's a question as to whether
that was the case in Russia and then the rest of
the vaccine opposition in the US is based on
either you don't think the vaccine will work,
you don't trust the companies that are making
the vaccines. You believe you don't need the
vaccine because your risk of getting covid is
very low. So the US and accept. Channel Country
standing out as one of the top two anti VAX
countries along with Russia. I believe that
the US is special and it's special in the amount
of conspiratorial thinking that people fall for
and often with really complicated explanations for
stuff that are far more complicated than the real
explanation. And it's a culmination of decades
of terrible education for much of the country,
terrible news sources that these people count on
which push this stuff, not understanding science,
which again, sort of links back to education
in many cases, and a Republican Party that
has adopted most of the worst instincts
about every issue and a polarization
that seems to make everything, even a virus masks
vaccines. Everything becomes political. This is
the culmination of that globally high vaccine
opposition. When the vaccine is the solution,
the vaccine is the solution to the Delta variant.
The vaccine is the solution to the pandemic. Now,
the good news is still 80 percent
of the country will get vaccinated,
or at least probably will. There's an 11 percent
slice that says they're unsure right now,
but only 20 percent like only is definitely
opposed to the vaccine. If we were to get to
80 percent vaccination, we would absolutely crush
this virus, delta variant and all. So if we want
to find something positive here, that is exactly
what it would be. We'll have more coverage of this
on our Instagram page. So make sure
you're following us there at David
Pakman show and make sure you're following
me on Instagram as well at David Pakman